bonjour et bienvenue dans ce nouveau
numéro de parlement hebdo au compas et
mickaël zeze bonjour mickey après une
semaine de vacances la vie parlementaire
reprend et nous aussi
une semaine politique marquée par une
virée de deux jours en provence en
province pardon du président hollande
nouvelle stratégique terrain pour tenter
d'enrayer la chute dans les sondages le
président s'est rendu à dijon sur les
terres de françois rebsamen visite un
peu chahuté sauver la majorité va l'être
aussi avec une motion censure déposée
cette semaine par l'ump à l'assemblée
nationale elle sera discutée mercredi
prochain cette unicité initiative de
jean françois copé
certains députés ump en ont pris
connaissance par la presse
enfin députés des sénateurs risquent de
voir leurs vacances d'été raccourcies
il pourrait revoir en juillet un congrès
à versailles pour voter une réforme
constitutionnelle
celle ci a été dévoilée cette semaine en
conseil des ministres réforme a minima
qui laisse de côté pour l'instant le
droit de vote des étrangers est avec
nous pour commenter toute cette
actualité roger karoutchi bonjour
bonjour sénateur ump des hauts-de-seine
mais aussi vice-président fait partie de
cette armée mexicaine délice président
de l'ump faisait la mode sud-américaine
latino-américaine pour l'avenir du
métier de directeur de la campagne de
jean françois copé mais évidemment de
l'ump vous allez nous en parler parce
qu'on imagine que tout ça vous ramène
quelques souvenirs une vie récit fait
des bons souvenirs ou pas des souvenirs
des souvenirs mais province on en
reparlera un petit peu plus tard mais il
est de tradition dans cette émission de
laisser la parole aux parlementaires
pour parler de vous propose de regarder
d'écouter
alors il a un certain talent du verbe
du mot il a une capacité j'allais dire à
faire partager ce qu'il ressent ce qu'il
perçoit ce qui est important pour un
homme politique
c'est vrai que ça s'inscrit dans une
forme de tradition mais je crois que
c'est bien qu'il y ait aussi au
parlement des orateurs
c'est un sacré en politique fort
sympathique c'est un adversaire
politique nous ne partageons pas les
mêmes idées et les confrontations sont
forcément tonique mais je pense qu'il
est peut-être un peu différent que
d'autres d'ailleurs alors les gens
d'ile-de-france me dirai peut-être pas
ça mais tel que je le vois ici
oui comme vous dites entre guillemets
cet animal politique sympathique malin
rusé et qui arrivent beaucoup à ses fins
par voie la part des discussions par par
des sourires partout cela oui c'est
quelqu'un avec lequel on peut vraiment
discuter roger karoutchi là une magie
lorsqu'on veut réussir une fête
militante
on invite roger karoutchi il séduit
l'auditoire c'est à la fois un galabru
intellectuelle et tout le monde l'a d'or
donc c'est une garantie de succès roger
karoutchi
il est très dangereux ah non il est pas
dans le jeu quand on l'est son ami est
un peu comme moi je savais que pierre
charon vous ferait beaucoup rire viala
brute s'est bien trouvés sais pas ce que
ça veut dire donc je me méfiais je pense
que ça veut dire des labos
intellectuelle no use ou poche padoue
table est votre ami vous savez j'ai
plutôt la réputation de ne pas être ni
un guerrier ni un type méchant j'ai
toujours appelé compris de la roue
j'ai la réputation de respecter mes
adversaires on me le reproche
suffisamment par rapport à jean paul
huchon présent que j'ai toujours
combattu dont j'ai toujours combattu la
politique mais que je respecte en tant
qu'homme et au parlement comme dans la
vie publique je peux critiquer combattre
les politiques
j'ai été formé comme ça je n'ai pas de
haine je n'ai pas d'animosité et
j'ai été formé pour écouter beaucoup me
remettre en question souvent et donc
essayer d'avancer
voilà je passe plus par la discussion
je suis plus un homme de consensus que
de contradictions avec les fillonnistes
jeu c'est une période quand je n'ai pas
apprécié j'ai conduit cette campagne
dont jean françois copé je pense avec
une certaine efficacité mais je n'aime
pas je n'aime pas les commentaires que
j'ai pu voir ici ou là même pas dans ce
conflit
moi je suis resté en bons termes avec
françois fillon en bons termes avec eric
ciotti voilà j'ai pas de jeu je suis pas
du tout quelqu'un qui vit dans le
conflit ou laine est ce que ça empêche
toute ambition est ce qu on dit souvent
qu'une politique c'est à dire que moi je
veux pas fait de calcul vous savez quand
j'ai commencé à faire la politique duré
16 ans je me suis engagé juste après 68
pour de gaulle
et puis après j'ai travaillé avec des
gens aussi différents que philippe c'est
un nicolas sarkozy donc ça je me suis
retrouvé député européen mini sénateurs
est ce que demain je serai à nouveau
ministre si nicolas le souhaite tant
mieux sinon oui ah ben il ya peu de
chances que françois hollande m'appelle
mais bon on sait pas candidat pour les
élections régionales oui j'ai dis très
tranquillement très sereinement que
comme je n'avais pas apprécié la main on
s'était passé les primaires des
régionales de 2009
je souhaitais qu'on tourne la page en
étant candidat sur un projet au bail
mercier attendez vous dites face à va
d'abord à lol non mais le système n'est
pas fermée regarder à paris ils sont
cinq peut-être six il y aura
probablement pour les régionales c'est
en 2015 sera probablement trois ou
quatre peut être cinq candidats alors
chacun aura son projet l'essentiel c'est
que ça se passe bien
manière transparente et que le résultat
soit accepté par tous
si je gagne parce que tout le monde se
rassemblera et si je perds si ça s'est
passé correctement
je soutiendrai naturellement celui ou
celle qui sera devant
roger karoutchi vous allez déroulée avec
nous le fil de la semaine c'est le
principe de l'émission commence
évidemment être le lundi voyage
présidentiel en terre dijonnaise
c'est une opération immersion 48 heures
en terre dijonnaise au contact de la
population
un bol d'air pour le président de la
république avec évidemment des sondages
en berne ils voulaient voir le coeur des
français
il a été salée reportage françois
hollande voulait du concret rien
d'artificiel une parole libre bref
reprendre contact avec les français
comme au bon vieux temps de la campagne
présidentielle
de ce côté-là ses voeux ont été exaucés
ne précisait pas trop les retrouver
l'envié pas impressionné car en l ou
pressurer pas trop là un petit peu déçu
parce que et nous a promis beaucoup de
choses et voilà donc peut-être qui nous
a promis trop de choses mais désormais
les français lui demande des comptes aux
efforts
monsieur hollande elle sous les
promesses à à elles sont pas vraiment au
bout d'un service d'ordre sur les dents
pas de quoi perturber le président qui
trace son chemin
comment ça se passe au lycée comme fille
comme
les études qui conduisait un an
ils y croient
certes il est venu écouter il le fait
mais aussi vanté les mérites de sa
politique
avec toujours un poivrier donc là les
emplois d'avenir ça va être
essentiellement vers cette jeunesse des
quartiers qui nous interpelle nous dit
qu'est-ce qui nous est prévu pour nous
qui a envie de travailler
la visite s'est consumé un petit peu
plus tard dans un bar l'occasion pour le
chef de l'état dessous faire un petit
peu et de repartir de plus belle à la
rencontre des français
c'est pas tous acquis à sa cause
loin de là mais au contact c'était pour
lui l'essentiel de cette première
journée
roger karoutchi un bon coup de com ses
déplacements à dijon pas au je suis pas
sûr un franchement s'il était pierre
richard g à la moutarde me monte au nez
mais l'aca serment bord qu'est ce que
voulez que je vous dise le tibet afin de
préserver public va à dijon lille sur
quoi tu ça en vrai qu'elle est là non ce
qui en soi rien alors il dit mais je
suis pas venu faire des annonces venues
écouter les français les français le
discours il ya eu un discours lors de la
2e journée où il ya quand même du fond
des annonces bon vous avez retenu non
les déficits
je veux dire dis toujours la même chose
il ya toujours ces fameux 60 engagement
qui ne sont d'ailleurs pas tenu
l'opinion publique lui est très hostile
aujourd'hui pas parce que ya la crise la
crise elle préexistait sensualité en
tout cas c'est ma pas le sujet le sujet
c'est plutôt de se dire attendez ils ont
fait campagne
lui et ses amis politiques sur abba
sarko ouais ça recule populiste sarko
qui était trop proche des gens
finalement quelque part et en même temps
trop éloignés enfin c'était un peu un
jeu incroyable et en même temps voilà
hollande qui a dit où pendant toute sa
campagne moi je resterai très au dessus
je m'impliquerai pas et puis comme il
voit que tout s'écroule il dit va
falloir y aller il y va mais c'est pas
mieux sa politique n'est pas acceptée
sans équipe est totalement en dans le
dysfonctionnement et les français ont
peur ils ont peur il ya la crise mais
ils ont surtout peur de se dire ou es ce
qui nous emmène ces gens parce qu au
moins du temps de nicolas sarkozy tous
ne marchait pas à merveille un je dis
pas le contraire mais il y avait une
ligne on avait le sentiment qu'ils
avaient une politique était conduite
vraiment sur un chemin pour vous que le
sondage ifop qui est paru cette semaine
dans paris match fait changer les
courbes essais littéraires sarkozy type
à deux pas du recul le côté il est
simple on a l'impression que l'équipe
gouvernementale d'aujourd'hui la
politique du président la république
elle est dans le domaine des courbes
elle plutôt sinusoïdale c'est à dire
qu'on sait plus bien où il va lui même
je pense que lui non plus un coup sur
les retraites ouailles et là à dijon il
dîne alors pas question pressurer deux
jours après on n'a pas en tout cas la
taxation qu'elle blocage sur les
retraites complémentaires calais
taxation sur les retraites donc en vrai
voilà quoi
qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent eux mêmes le
soft probablement pas allez on va passer
au mardi va barder il ya de la censure
dans l'air
jean françois copé l'avait annoncé il ya
un mois il l'a fait cette semaine dépôt
d'une motion de censure qui sera débattu
mercredi prochain par les députés
elles visent notamment à sanctionner la
politique économique du gouvernement
aucune chance bien sûr d'être adoptée
mais à l'offre une tribune aux députés
ump et tout particulièrement évidemment
au président de l'ump est un sujet de
timo le floch ne faisons pas durer le
suspense artificiellement non la motion
de censure que l'ump va déposer ne
devrait pas être adopté mercredi
prochain car les socialistes sont
majoritaires dans l'hémicycle alors à
quoi tout cela peut-il bien servir une
motion de censure ça sert à dire ce que
vous faites c'est pas bien voilà ce que
nous on aurait fait alors c'est vrai
qu'elle ne sera probablement pas adopté
comme les amendements qu'on dépose mais
si vous voulez qu'on supprime
l'opposition faut le dire ce sera
beaucoup plus rapidement
sans en arriver à de telles extrémités
les députés de la droite savent qu'avec
cette motion ils sont plus dans la
démonstration de leur mécontentement que
dans l'action l'opposition est dans son
rôle lorsqu'elle effectivement sous les
caméras de télévision à la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale prend à témoin le
peuple français de jeux virait la
mauvaise politique conduite par ce
gouvernement et qui sera devant ses
caméras pour les trier la politique de
l'exécutif
jean françois copé évidemment le
président de l'ump cherche à asseoir son
image de premier opposant
grâce à cette motion dont le vote sera
précédé d'un débat au sein de
l'hémicycle
une nouvelle occasion pour la droite de
montrer une image d'unité
après les divisions qu'elle a connu en
décembre dernier c'est un moment de
rassemblement donc tant mieux si l'ump
peut se rassembler tant mieux
l'opposition rassemblée ce pas une bonne
nouvelle pour le parti socialiste c'est
une bonne nouvelle pour nos côtés
socialiste les députés attendent de pied
ferme ce débat leur argumentaire et déjà
trouver les responsables de l'état de la
france ce sont ceux qui étaient au
pouvoir
avant eux un angle d'attaqué qu'ils ont
déjà eu l'occasion de tester lors de
l'été 2009
en déposant une motion censure contre le
gouvernement de françois fillon
alors roger karoutchi le sénateur que
vous êtes ne sera que spectateur ogre
éternel alors c'est la constitution
n'ose pas frustrer les députés font leur
job le sénateur feu le font bien le leur
au regard des régulièrement balle
gouvernement donc ça va bien vous savez
les motions de censure adoptée sous la
vème république sont rarissimes
il ya eu celle de 62 qui a conduit
d'ailleurs à la dissolution à une
majorité encore plus large autour du
général de gaulle
mais les motions de censure à partir du
moment où il ya une majorité nos
positions on sait bien que la majorité
la refuse
à quoi ça sert on sait que vous avez pas
faire tomber le gouvernement du temps
coeur blessé
j'allais presque dire à un moment le
temps politique est très rapide le temps
médiatique est encore plus rapide jours
à jour heure à heure vous dites voilà
l'info voilà match la motion de censure
ses poses on va vous faire le bilan
on va vous dire mesdames et messieurs en
dix mois
ce qu'a fait la gauche qui ne va pas et
par conséquent ça permet de un peu de
stabiliser l'actualité sur un bilan
économique et politique parce que
sincèrement je sais bien le gouvernement
veut dire oui héritage et il est prêt à
l'ump françois fillon
pourquoi pas un partage des tâches c'est
à dire qu il est assez rare que le
motion de censure puisse être un ami
temps pour deux d'ailleurs le
il est le président de l'ump est assez
logique que ce soit lui qui déforme ump
ont dit qu'ils avaient appris ça par les
médias s'est passé mérite à fait vrai
puisque il y avait eu une discussion en
bureau politique
et vous savez on nous reproche
suffisamment accès bureau politique soit
200 donc beaucoup de monde qui
discuteraient hees avait été évoquée
devant le bureau politique avant qui l
annonce officielle
alors certains peut-être ne vienne pas
aux réunions et pourtant elles sont
ouvertes on ne peut pas dire mais bon
voilà alors il je pense que tout le
monde tout le monde peut savoir tout y'a
pas puis sincèrement pas un secret
d'état déposé une motion de censure
d'abord vous l'a déposé elle est en
réalité tu dis que des semaines plus
tard donc il faut du temps je me suis
loupé c'est le principal opposant à
françois hollande aujourd'hui à la fois
dans son rôle de président l'ump et dans
ce cas sa tradition son armature mentale
et politique
il est fait pour l'opposition il a un
côté guerrier chefs de guerre qui qui
lui permet d'être un opposant résolu et
un opposant déterminé qu'une bonne
rotation c'est pas du tout ce que j'ai
dit oui et comme vous êtes
non mais françois fillon est un opposant
aussi résolu c'est comme tom univers
c'est pas le sujet en l'occurrence parce
que pour la motion de censure il aurait
probablement fait un discours aussi fort
aussi critique de la politique
socialiste que veut le faire jean
françois copé
mais à un moment il y en a qu'un qui
veut le faire la logique c'est le
président de l'uefa
mais ce n'est pas à l'ump pourquoi
voulez vous savez c'est pas la guerre
permanente il se soit entre guillemets
entendu il ya un accord et c'est très
bien
la mairie vous avez dit roger karoutchi
faire une pause
regardez quel est le bilan et vous avez
dit également aussi en revenus qu'on va
vous a renvoyé l'héritage écouter ce que
dit zemmour naulleau
quand on voit aujourd'hui que nous
essayons de redresser dix années de
laisser-aller dix années de déficit
public accumulé 10
allez d'endettement dix années de
destruction de l'école avoir une motion
de censure qui viennent nous dire que
nous serions aujourd'hui au bout de 10
mois responsable de ça cela côté un peu
comique qui peut d'ailleurs nous
permettre et qui va nous permettre
d'apporter des réponses la semaine
prochaine très précise à ce qui va être
dit par monsieur côté bien au contraire
et c'est pas comme ça la vérité c'est
que nicolas sarkozy n'a jamais dit que
pendant qu'il y est et après 2008 et va
de crise et a eu la crise financière et
la crise financière très lourde très dur
qui est qui et 2008 2010 a été une crise
qui a impliqué que l'état s'engage
davantage pour protéger les filets
sociaux pour maintenir l'investissement
et a donc c'est vrai qu'il ya une
déficit si je puis dire de protection ce
qu'on reproche aux socialistes c'est par
la crise la crise elle est là pour tout
le monde c'est que face à cette crise
au lieu de prendre des mesures pour
réduire les déficits comme on s'y était
engagé comme on avait bien commencé à le
faire en 2011 2012 au lieu de maintenir
par exemple la revue générale des
politiques publiques et vlan ancrée
60000 postes dans l'éducation
au lieu de dire on maintient le cadre
des dépenses on lâche sur un certain
nombre de choses on remet en cause la
réforme des retraites et puis maintenant
d'ailleurs on risque d'avoir une oeuvre
d'art est plus dure que celle que nous
avons votée nous après l'avoir remis en
cause se dire que c'est la nuit la
narration c'est une adaptation mais ils
feraient bien de s'adapter vite mais le
réalisme socialiste s'est très vite
maintenant s'ils veulent s'en sortir
parce que vous avez des gens très
réaliste mots je pense tous par exemple
mise du budget kate jack est quelqu'un
qui sait compter et qui de temps en
temps d'hier la sonnette d'alarmé chez
ses voisins des autres militaires de la
junkie les mecs mais on va finir sur la
paille
donc vous avez raison
oui bah oui mais il faut c'est toujours
les premières mesures nous a beaucoup
reproché
rappelez-vous 2007 tout ce qui était le
texte fameux texte est pas moi je trouve
que la leur motion leur leur politique
de 2012 a été catastrophique
maintenant ils se rendent compte que la
crise est très grave ils vont essayer
mais ce que ça n'est pas un peu tard on
a découragé l'initiative par la
fiscalité
les mesures symboliques comme le 75%
comme les débats sur ouais les patrons
qui parlent et machado
tout ça crée un climat épouvantable bas
donc motion de censure parce que à un
moment il faut reprendre les choses en
main le réquisitoire ce sera un mercredi
en direct
vous parliez de l'école roger karoutchi
mardi toujours les députés examinent le
texte sur la refondation de l'école
renforcement de la formation initiale
des enseignants priorité au direct aux
primaires pardo et surtout création de
60000 postes la mesure était votée en
fin de semaine
c'était une promesse phare du candidat
hollande et je vous vois hoché la tête
et on n'est pas là pour parler tout ça
très vite et d'abord le sujet de betty
lachguer dès lundi le ministre de
l'éducation avait tenté de rendre une
copie parfaite face un hémicycle quelque
peu vide
nous devons être capables dans ce débat
si vous le souhaitez de dépasser des
postures partisanes
la méthode que je vous propose elle est
une méthode de rassemblement un exposé
de 45 minutes où il a aussi détaillé le
coeur de sa loire la priorité donnée aux
primaires avec plus de postes
l'accès à l'école pour les enfants de
moins de 3 ans et la réduction des
redoublements
le ton est monté dès ce mardi lors des
questions au gouvernement la députée ump
dominique nachury pointe du doigt ces
crispations
quelle déception monsieur le ministre
notre école et nos enfants méritait
mieux
vous nous avez habitués de belles
envolées lyriques dans cet hémicycle
mais nous attendons des réponses
concrètes quand allez vous admettre que
cette réforme est mal conçu
réponse agacée de vincent peillon qui ne
peut s'empêcher de critiquer l'action de
la précédente majorité
si ce que vous recherchez c'est
l'intérêt des élèves de france vous ne
l'avez pas manifesté pendant dix ans je
vous tends la main autour d'une oeuvre
patrie mais celles auxquelles allez je
vous appelle à l'aider chers collègues
on retrouve son calme
l'ump vent debout contre le texte et
plus particulièrement contre l'article 1
examiner dans la soirée c'est celui qui
définit la programmation des moyens et
des orientations et surtout celui qui
crée les 60000 postes promis par
françois hollande sur ce point
l'offensive a été vive
cet article 1 un titre bien pompeux il
prétend refonder l'école de la
république franchement mes chers
collègues monsieur le ministre
croyez vous que ce texte refonde l'école
de la république la réponse hélas est
évidente elle est négatif les députés de
l'opposition ont ensuite présenté une
série d'amendements demandant tout
simplement la suppression de cet article
sans surprise ils sont tous rejeté
jusqu'à la suspension de la séance à
nous ni roger karoutchi vous avez été
professeur d'histoire à exercer ce beau
métier pendant 15 ans d'être forcément
d'accord avec certaines des losers
notamment le retour à la formation
initiale des enseignants et sur la
formation des enseignants on peut en
débattre
moi j'étais pas très favorable lorsqu'il
ya eu un certain nombre de créations du
styliste faibles etc mais mais il faut
en débattre parce que c'est vrai que je
considère qu'aujourd'hui déjà de mon
temps la formation des enseignants est
extraordinairement théorique qui arrive
et demande à ses premiers élèves avec
une formation en histoire ancienne sur
les poteries proto corinthiennes dont je
vous raconte pas l'intérêt mais c'est
fascinant mais la suppression des stages
pour nicolas sarkozy ce n'était pas une
bonne idée c'est bien les remettre
on peut discuter sur les stages même si
j'ai pas un souvenir extraordinaire la
matière a en revanche ce qui est vrai
c'est que sincèrement
je le dis gentiment parce que vous jouez
pas d'animosité à l'égard de monsieur
peillon avec je fais des débats plutôt
d'un bon niveau un temps mais soixante
mille créations de postes c'est
surréaliste gers et traiter le mal de
l'éducation nationale en considérant
bien continuons de considérer que ce
n'est que du quantitatif
ça n'est pas vrai ça n'est pas prêt mais
non ce n'est pas vrai il ya beaucoup de
moyens dans l'éducation nationale
ils sont très mal répartie ils sont très
mal distribuées et il faut remettre à
plat
mais chaque fois qu'il ya un problème
dans l'éducation nationale on va créer
des postes mais ça suffit pas il ya un
certain nombre de règles
vous savez aujourd'hui j'étais aussi
décidément ambassadeur auprès de l' ocde
l' ocde qui fait un classement qu'il
veut le fameux classement pisa sur le
classement éducation nous n'étions
malheureusement sur les quelques trente
quatre membres de l' ocde
nous étions 20e très loin derrière la
corée du sud pourquoi parce que notre
système éducatif coûtait plus cher que
les autres et avaient moins de moins
bons résultats il faut une réflexion non
juste parce qu'il faudrait plus de
braseros moins de 10 ans il faut une
infection sur les programmes saint
thurien du love que les autres oui mais
pourquoi créer d'abord des postes alors
qu'on n'a pas d'argent avant gaza
enfin moi aussi j'étais en c'est dire
que monde et bien sûr mais moi aussi
j'étais enseignant et on faisait grève
pas moi mais chaque fois qu'il fallait
un truc on disait les trois potes de
plus devant dont cinq poteaux
bien sûr c'est la facilité mais enfin
d'abord travaillons sur les programmes
travaillons sur les méthodes éducatives
travaillons sur les méthodes de contrôle
de l'air de lyon sur les rythmes
scolaires
oui mais impossible parce que ça
ministère au bon peut-être oui
parce que c'est impossible mission
impossible ça plaît bien mais non mais
au-delà de ça t'a mystère fascinant
parce que c'est la formation des jeunes
et en même temps c'est un mystère énorme
est lourd et le problème c'est que pour
remettre enfin vous pas vous êtes plus
jeune que moi mais quand on était jeunes
on était sur le culte de notre système
éducatif moi je suis un pur produit de
l'école laïque et républicaine et on
nous disait à l'époque et on se disait
nous mêmes enfants
on est dans l'un des meilleurs systèmes
éducatifs du monde et c'était vrai ça
n'est plus vrai et ça n'est pas qu'un
problème de moyens c'est un problème de
conception de l'enseignement
karoutchi au pinceau mercredi le
gouvernement l'annoncent il y aura bien
une réforme de la constitution
et oui effectivement ce mercredi le
conseil des ministres se penche sur la
future réforme constitutionnelle elle
prendra la forme de quatre projets de
loi qui devront être examinés par les
deux assemblées avant de passer
probablement fin juillet devant le
congrès à versailles
il faudra alors une large majorité des
trois cinquièmes et c'est sans doute
pour cela que le gouvernement a voulu
ces textes les plus consensuel possible
les explications d'elisa berthelot mais
pour éviter un désaveu politique
l'exécutif a voulu se montrer malin
ce n'est pas un projet mais quatre qui
seront proposés aux parlementaires des
projets qui reprennent certaines
promesses du candidat hollande mais pas
de gros chamboulements la réforme et
consensuelle j'ai présenté en effet
quatre projets de loi qui s'inscrivent
dans la volonté du président de la
république de moderniser nos
institutions de créer davantage de
confiance dans ses institutions
un premier projet de loi réforme eura le
conseil supérieur de la magistrature
un deuxième inscrira le dialogue social
dans la constitution un troisième projet
supprime pas la cour de justice de la
république
enfin un quatrième texte mettra fin au
statut de membre de droit au conseil
constitutionnel des anciens présidents
de la république et interdira aux
ministres de cumuler avec un exécutif
local abandonné pour l'instant
l'ouverture du droit de vote des
étrangers aux élections locales la
suppression du mot race de la
constitution et l'inscription de la
laïcité dans la loi fondamentale
abandonné également la réforme du statut
pénal du chef de l'état
seul son statut civil sera modifiée dans
le domaine civil il sera désormais mis
fin à l'immunité dont bénéficiait le
président de la république le président
de la république pourra d'aller bien
faire l'objet d'une action de droit
civil dans les conditions du droit
commun mais après autorisation donnée
par la commission des requêtes qui est
mentionnée à l'article 68 de la
constitution
quatre projets donc et autant de chances
de parvenir à en faire adopter quelques
uns
car toute modification de la
constitution nécessite le vote de trois
cinquièmes des parlementaires
or jusqu'à présent l'opposition refuse
de soutenir une quelconque réforme
constitutionnelle autant de propositions
qui si on est de bonne foi doit faire
l'objet d'un large consensus
je dirais même bien au delà d'une
majorité des trois cinquièmes au congrès
pour réviser cette constitution parce
que ça participe à renforcement de la
transparence
les quatre projets seront d'abord
présenté devant le parlement un congrès
sera réuni à versailles
au mois de juillet roger karoutchi vous
allez devoir sûrement sacrifier une
partie de vos vacances et comme sa part
elisa berthelot mais l'a bien expliqué
c'est un texte édulcoré finalement vous
voulez vous était telle qu'il est là
problème qui est à la demande président
la république en 2008 conduit les débats
sur la réforme constitutionnelle avec
rachida dati qui est vécu ce fameux
congrès de juillet 2008
franchement convoquer un congrès pour ça
non mais franchement ça fait perdre de
temps au cccc au delà du 2 au delà de
tout moi je trouve que même ses presque
humiliant pour les parlementaires
franchement c'est pas le fait que ce
soit en juillet en juin en mai ou en
septembre sur les versailles 1 enfin
attendu mais à la limite
après il y avait un vrai débat moi
j'étais contre
parti en contre attaque alors on va
faire une réforme la constitution s'ils
veulent plus mettre grand chose dans
cette réforme parce qu'ils n'en fassent
pas enfin ça que j'en sais rien enfin
sincèrement si ça finit juste par dire
les anciens présidents public n'iront
pas au conseil constitutionnel à sa
sauce et c'est sur c'est tous les jours
en se levant se disent ce que françois
hollande ira au conseil constutionnel
ils répondent non mais bon c'est pas le
sujet les vous kiffe attendait on est en
plein dans les débats sur l'emploi sur
la fiscalité sur le pouvoir d'achat et
on vienne nous casser les pieds avec une
mini réforme constitutionnelle qui n'en
est pas une et qui ne touchez pas à la
constitution quand y'a rien à y mettre
de nouveau il faut toucher à la
constitution
quand on la change vraiment quand on a
rien à dire on se tait voilà c'est dur
pour rien mais c'est une procédure pour
rien on va encore passer des jours et
des jours parce que avant le congrès
tous ces trucs là vont passer à
l'assemblée au sénat
tout ça va durer encore des semaines
enfin attendez les français ils méritent
autre chose ils attendent autre chose
on en a rien à faire de ça alors on va
passer à autre chose alors prêt semblant
de l'adie a dijon il ya trop de
lourdeurs administratives ça sur mon
sort et on s'assure bon d'accord ça ne
va pas assez vite là aussi vous serez
d'accord le gouvernement pourrait donc
utiliser un droit qui est dans la
constitution que ce taux qui s'appelle
lors de nos nous dire est ce que vous en
pensez
c'est à dire faire passer une loi sans
forcément passer par la voie
parlementaire
écoutez cet échange assez vif dans
l'hémicycle du sénat entre gérard
larcher et le ministre de l'intérieur
manuel valls on passe tellement de temps
monsieur le ministre
et vous-même au parlement sur ces sujets
électoraux qui pouvait attendre qu'on en
oublie l'essentiel la compétitivité
l'emploi l'économie au poids que ce
matin sur ces sujets essentiels de
conseil des ministres décide de
légiférer par ordonnances privant le
sénat et l'assemblée nationale et le
législateur de son rôle le père y en un
public est intervenu hier dans un
discours important à dijon sur notamment
les blocages que la société française
connaissait sur le moyen d'y arriver
il ya évidemment la loi peut y avoir
aussi les ordonnances dans ce domaine là
il a notamment évoqué la question du
logement
d'autres sujets peuvent être traitées
d'autres gouvernements ou utilisez déjà
les ordonnances vous le savez bien sont
inscrits dans la constitution mais quand
le problème se posera j'imagine que le
débat aura lieu à roger karoutchi s'est
inscrit dans la constitution
donc le gouvernement on peut le faire ce
sont des textes très technique bâtiment
non les ordonnances c'est quoi un
système vous avez d'abord une loi
d'habilitation c est faux quand même
venir devant le parlement une première
fois pour un débat d'habilitation
général ensuite vous prenez le texte les
décrets et ensuite il faut les faire
ratifier un à l'issue quand même y'a
quand même des parlementaires
ça n'a d'intérêt les ordonnances que sur
une politique globale
le général de gaulle met la france en
d'aplomb en 86 87 une série
d'ordonnancés parce que c'était sur
l'emploi l'emploi des jeunes le handicap
tête à tête avec ça comme ça c'était à
mon avis une erreur bonfa sociale des
global it des politiques globales où il
faut intervenir tout de suite là on nous
dit quoi on nous dit alors on voudrait
guerre les barreaux d'un sur quoi sur le
logement et l'urbanisme
attendez pardon mais sur le logement
mais à peine de voter un texte de loi
logement
si madame duflot voulait mettre des
choses différentes dans ce texte de loi
fait surtout pas qu'elle ça n'empêche et
se priva la dgta une fois devant le
conseil constitutionnel
elle pourrait remettre donc quel est
l'intérêt de faire les rues des
ordonnances sur le logement
trois mois après l'adoption d'un texte
de loi sur le logement sur les normes
mais sur les normes
vous n'avez pas besoin d'ordonnancé moi
j'ai demandé par exemple pour la
réalisation des chantiers publics du
grand paris à ce qu'on assouplissent les
normes pour aller plus vite parce que
quand barcelone fait un périphérique en
métro il ya ils le font en cinq sets en
nous il faut 20 ans à ordonnance mais
pourquoi sur des choses aussi précise la
loi suffit l'intérêt des ordres
mais l'intérêt des ordonnances séquence
et une batterie qu'il faut aller dans
plusieurs secteurs et que donc vous avez
une espèce de système qui permet de
dégager quelque chose là sur un secteur
c'est ridicule la loi suffit le
parlement a l'impression d'être
contournée pourquoi mais parce qu'on
vienne passé des semaines à discuter à
débattre d'un texte logements un peu
trop longtemps parfois l'assemblée cette
semaine sur l'école un seul ordre du
jour les ans mais ça le moi j'ai dit que
je travaille parlementaires devaient
être on l'a déjà avec j'ai eu
suffisamment de critiques là dessus avec
eux le fameux temps compté partager à
l'assemblée qui n'existe pas au sénat
mais moi je suis pas un fanatique de la
masse énorme d'amendements sur le texte
mariage six mille amendements à
l'assemblée et au sénat y en aura six
ans donc déjà c'est pas les mêmes
conceptions de travail il faut
travailler plus en commission et moi un
hémicycle
il faut concentrer les textes mais il
faut aussi que le gouvernement j'en
prends ma part de responsabilité mission
avant exactement les commissions qui
aujourd'hui sont finalement le passage
obligé d'un texte qui modifie le texte
puisque ces textes commission qui arrive
devant l'assemblée mais en fait en
l'assembleur recommence et donc là il ya
quelque chose dans la réforme qui est
pas bien bouclée il faudrait en fait
peut-être une main lorsqu'un texte a été
débattu en commission seuls les
amendements extérieur et nouveau
reviennent parce que sinon c'est trop
long allez on va passer au jeudi le
sénat ne veux vraiment pas décidément
d'un binôme hommes femmes pour les
départements
le texte a été voté mais on peut le dire
vraiment édulcorer les sénateurs ont
rejeté l'article phare l'article 2 une
deuxième fois il impose pour les
élections départementales la parité un
homme une femme ce coin rejeté par les
sénateurs ump par les centristes
aussi par les écologistes mais et
communistes pour d'autres raisons
et on peut le bien dire le gouvernement
a du mal à faire passer cette loi au
sénat les explications de jérôme
rhabiller pour l'adoption 137 contre 185
le sénat n'a pas adopté l'article 2 au
grand dam du gouvernement et de manuel
valls
le sénat a de nouveau rejeté l'article
créant le binôme hommes femmes pour les
élections cantonales
après un premier rejet en janvier la
deuxième lecture n'a pas permis
d'obtenir la majorité communiste vers
centriste et ump laissant seul le ps
soutenir cette proposition
il y avait l'occasion d'un rendez vous
et ce rendez vous il va être manqué une
nouvelle fois mais comme l'assemblée
nationale aura de toute façon le dernier
mot et autorisera la création du binôme
les sénateurs ont préféré ne pas rejeter
d'emblée l'article mais on discute et
permettant la suite de l'examen dû texte
le sénat doit continuer à peser sur
cette question il ya un désaccord mais
sur toutes les autres questions de la
loi il ya des apports
ce serait dommage que tous ces débats
qui sont très riches
que nous avons depuis de nombreuses
heures et bien arrive en cmp puis se
compter dans la loi finale car le texte
aborde d'autres aspects électoraux
notamment le nombre d'habitants à partir
duquel l'élection municipale se fait à
la proportionnelle pour peser sur le
texte final le sénat a préféré
poursuivre la discussion
et pourquoi pas ensuite voter le texte
sans le binôme paritaire ce mode de
scrutin était un des points les plus
négatifs de ce texte le fait qu'il ait
été rejetée peut conduire on le verra ce
soir ou demain peut conduire à ce que
finalement le texte dans sa globalité ne
soit pas rejetée
en agissant ainsi les sénateurs pourront
négocier à minima avec l'assemblée
nationale lors de la commission mixte
paritaire qui rédigera une version
commune de cette loi électorale
finalement donc le texte a été adopté
dans la nuit roger karoutchi le scrutin
binominal un homme une femme a été
rejetée par par l'ump
c'était pas la seule raison du rejet de
ce texte jack et des raisons cachées
aussi non écoutez comme une femme très
content mais alors attendait d'abord
sincèrement ça revient parce que j'ai
tout à l'heure sur les histoires de
réforme constitutionnelle d tout le
monde se plaint de la fiscalité des
problèmes de logement des problèmes
pouvoir d'achat des craintes pour
l'avenir
qu'est ce que fait ce gouvernement irait
forme les modes de scrutin de tous et
législatives mais une part de attendait
mais une part de proportionnelle des
sénatoriales et je vous fais 2 1 avant
le scrutin proportionnel à partir de 3
ans on change le corps électoral
machettes ou des cantonales mais mais
c'est quoi ce jeu enfin franchement il a
ils ont rien d'autre à faire au
gouvernement qu'à essayer de conserver
leur majorité dans les différentes vues
de morpho attendu ils se disent bon si
jamais une vague lors à s'entendre une
alors plutôt que d'en prendre une on va
vous changer le mode de scrutin dans les
petits de lille on va vous changer le
mode de scrutin cantonal ont rôdé coupe
c'est eux qui ont les ciseaux quand même
pour redécouper parce que quand on dit à
un homme une femme comme avons refusé sa
belle série mais c'est quoi du fin seul
le problème le problème c'est que par
exemple dans mon département des
hauts-de-seine
nous avons 45 ans sont aujourd'hui sa
face avant
moi qui redécoupe eux comment ils vont
faire vous croyez qu'ils vont aider la
droite a gagné des sièges
donc on a bien compris que sous couvert
de regarder la parité comment vous
refusez la parité quel méchant garçon
vous êtes en réalité moi je tiens et si
d'aucuns pour fait les comptes ont
évidemment donc à un mouvement c'est ça
pour être propre bien sûr bien sûr mais
je ne doute pas que manuel valls
lui-même le pense mais ceux qui tiennent
les ciseaux comme ça remonte par
définition plutôt du côté socialiste
d'une autre vers le gouvernement les
propositions sont pas exactement celle
que nous falloir changer pour l'excédent
des futures sénatoriales ou pas ça va
vraiment compter le pouvoir gagner
éventuellement le simple fait par
exemple de passer la proportionnelle au
lieu de quatre sénateurs par département
à 3 on n'a compté que ça leur faisait
mécaniquement gagner en 2014 six ou sept
sièges le simple fait d'ajouter des
grands électeurs au delà de 30 milles au
lieu de 1 pour 1000 1 pour 8 cents on
n'a compté que ça leur faisait
mécaniquement gagné 4 à 5 sièges ce qui
veut dire que règne par les réformes pas
par le corps électoral
anne par les réformes les tipis se sont
mis dix dossiers dans la poche en disant
si jamais on perd les municipales fait
un peu de marge quoi mais ça n'existait
bien sûr de ça existe et est ce que j'ai
l'air de dire ça sauf que jeudi on est
en pleine crise économique et financière
les gens ont peur de l'avenir et on
réforme le mans de scrutin cantonal on
reporte les régionales on touche aux
sénatoriales en roumanie par de propos
sur la relative à ce qu'on dit mais il
aurait pu perdre à faire
ah oui aux leurs une commission mixte
paritaire
alors on continue et que cette semaine
évidemment habemus papam
il s'appelle georges et mario bergoglio
excusez moi pour l'accent il est
argentin
on l'appellera voilà plus simplement le
pape françois ce 266e pape est le
souverain pontife qui cumule les
premières premier pape issus du
continent américain premier jésuites il
a entamé son premier discours aux
fidèles par cette petite phrase légère
mes frères cardinaux sont allé me
chercher presque au bout du monde
on présente un peu comme le porte parole
et les vérités celui qui refuseraient le
luxe aux fonctions vous y voyez un
changement de style à venir compenser au
vatican
je suis pas spécialiste des affaires du
vatican c'est vrai qu'on puisse dire
mais je pense que prendre un pape qui
n'est pas un européen c'est plutôt un
signe landes pour cent des caisses la
mairie c'est plutôt un signe positif
parce que l'europe ne peux pas croire
qu'elle est le centre du monde en
permanence il fait pas le job et
deuxième élément c'est pour la première
fois un jésuite
c'est une forme très différentes et on
va voir ce que ça comme conséquence qui
plus est il n'est pas issu de la curie
donc face à toutes les critiques sur la
gouvernance de qualité image plus plus
plus une approche réaliste à roger
karoutchi je voudrais qu'on termine
cette émission de sur une note de
musique un petit peu plus légère vous
aimez bien la chanson française de mai
la chanson même chanson française est-ce
que car la guinée est ce que j'en ai pas
expliqué carla bruni sarkozy vous a fait
écouter son dernier album
non il ya un titre dans son futur album
qui s'appelle le pingouin une chanson
qui fait beaucoup parler par ses paroles
aient su inspirer peut-être par les
images que vous voyez sur l'écran c'est
à l'époque évidemment de la passation de
pouvoir regarder ce texte il prend son
petit air souverain mais je le connais
moi le pingouin
il n'a pas la manière du châtelain ni là
ni benoît gouin niveau ni bas ni froid
ni chaud le pingouin ni oui ni non
elle rajoute elle pingouins si un jour
je te croise mon chemin je t'apprendrai
le pingouin je t'apprendrai à me faire
le baisemain mais vu les noms et break
c'était le surnom de françois hollande
donné par carla bruni sarkozy
visiblement c'est bien françois hollande
qui est aussi stigmatisé paul et comme
toujours
sincèrement je ne connaissais pas la
chanson je ne sais pas s'il ya la
moindre intention
quand je croise pas le sentiment que
celui-ci devait surnommait je le ferai
pas je vous rassure tout de suite c'est
pour conforter mon image de début
d'émission six levées sur nos mails
présent la pluie je n'appellerai pas le
pingouin parce que cet animal
sympathique le pingouin
ne le ferai pas voilà bon en tout cas
voilà sera sûrement le futur bien mais
ça fait beaucoup parler puisque
visiblement c'est une sorte de vengeance
visiblement sur cette passation de
pouvoir dire que barres d'or un jeu ce
pas du tout là sur la chanson mais moi
je trouvais que le comportement de
françois hollande à la sortie de nicolas
sarkozy le fait que en effet disparaître
quasiment nicolas saboly du site de
l'elysée
le fait d'oublier de remercier nicolas
sarkozy lors de la libération de
florence cassez tout c'est pas très
grand écoutez c'est sûr c'est beaucoup
mais nous séparer merci monsieur d'avoir
passé ces 45 minutes avec nous et on se
retrouve